Wow damn it feels good to be on time
another day still kickin it it's been
quite the eventful week to say the least
so much has happened so why not let's
just jump into it guys and review this
week
leave your entry in the server any crows
when you make a meme all by yourself but
you divide it to give some Karma to your
friend - is it two different people it
is Bravo well done this is two days ago
the gap has shrunk to 15k well not
anymore it really looked like it was the
end didn't me Joel and Dave recorded a
video for 16 hours straight just to make
sure that it would get a go out in time
but now it looks like we have literally
like weeks oh well not complaining 74
million this is so ridiculous how
welcome all new subscribers we post
memes here by the way if you expected
anything else I don't know what to tell
you literally millions of new
subscribers I hope you enjoy the memes
that we post on this channel
it's literally every single day thank
you very much
what an absolute legend someone hacked
printers worldwide urging people to
subscribe to PewDiePie I'll have you
know my mum thought this was hilarious
so thank you again hacker giraffe Dylan
the hacker put nothing at the end of
your videos put ass at the end of your
videos put ads at the end of your videos
put a clip from mine says channel at the
end and then have mine set claim the
video before anyone else to guarantee
that you get the revenue from the video
oh you know YouTube as a broken system
when ironic memes is actually fat
when idiotic ideas as a meme is an
actual good idea that's how you know you
have a broken system YouTube playing big
lasagna for 10 hours to save PD PI
versus T series Devi 504
he also made another video where he
played Biff lasagna on a lasagna then
again you could also play bit lasagna on
an actual lasagna that's the real reason
that's the real way to do it recently a
lot of Indian youtubers who have a
significant audience I've started making
videos again speedify many are of the
impression that he is desperate in
divinity series and he actually
disrespect the whole country of India
many of them are saying that he's hiding
behind sarcasm and means to show his
hate I as an Indian nine-year-old
understand it's not true but most of
them doesn't so maybe puce please
address this fact they are making it an
India versus West thing booths tell
everyone it's not like that in yes
t-series is Hindi you almost had a nice
wholesome message there until the very
end I saw this pose and I've seen a lot
of people addressing it and that's part
of the reason why I wanted to do the
charity campaign that we did so I
appreciate that you guys raised his
concerns to me as well and I hope we can
make a change and I hope I think we have
now already we raised in total two
hundred and fifty three thousand dollars
towards crying to help children in India
thank you again so much everyone that
showed up on the livestream and everyone
that donated ten thousand people over
ten thousand people donated and chipped
in thank you all so much and everyone
that just came to show your support as
well
amazing so proud honesty could not be
more proud of this audience right now
shout out to notch and markiplier for
their 10k donations thank you both very
much very cool what's up nine-year-olds
a few months ago I found this channel on
the subreddit because some tried to get
him on the why his name is Steven he
made drawings every day while he was in
the hospital sadly had cancer and even
worse it got the best of him as a final
goodbye to Steven subscribe
ideal guys are great in you and I am
just telling you guys I'm not gonna be
here forever because of the tumor they
um I have it's gonna make me die and
sorry if I'm trying a little bit when
things come the YouTube channel should
still be growing you guys should be
hitting the like button you know
remember I always be and you guys hurts
but it's gonna be okay so I'll see you
guys remember to hit the like button
subscribe and in the bone notification
and I'll see you guys in the next vid
peace out
hi everyone it's Papa weave mama weave
here you haven't heard from us in a
while or Steven actually I'm sorry
unfortunately he passed away on November
28th about a week ago or so and my wife
and I just want to tell you that we're
all so happy that you all have been
supportive for Steven weaving and we
just want to tell you that we're gonna
continue the channel we're so we're so
happy that the support that came through
for Steven that uh you know before he
died he told us that he wanted us to
continue the channel I'm gonna leave
Stevens channel in the description go
ahead and show your support and also
they have a make-a-wish fundraiser as
well for Steven in his name so I'll link
to that as well if you want to check
that out and maybe donate as well
I got real back - memes okay alright mr.
B's guys the battle with T series is
getting intense and casualties are high
can we call Logan and Jake fall for help
is winning worth sacrificing everything
yes okay all right
I wonder if Logan Paul would do it I
wonder could we put our differences
aside come on Logan what's it gonna be
that's right I'm back desperate I'll
take any help I can get the King the
King's right-hand the last hope the
general the infiltrator this sage the
virtue that's great
Thank You pewds he protect he attack but
most importantly he helps kids in India
get back on track
this is so wholesome can we smash
thousand subscribers this subscribe to
PewDiePie blah blah blah blah and blah
and honestly feel like I don't deserve
it
thank you for the caption there by the
way very nice that is why it must be
okay this is epic Johnny D did his part
by singing backless on Johnny D the sage
of the PewDiePie channel thank you as
always Johnny D you're an absolute
legend boogie2988 did is part YouTube is
about individuals not corporations
Francis eats only salad til PewDiePie
beats T series why did I not see that
did he actually do that
Thank You boogie is this a supermarket
no it's over there
k thanks why is this me Oh Peters
chopping adventure that actually sounds
like a good game what do I collect the
monetization come on get out of here
oh wait he's actually making a game are
you kidding me
I'm making a game for poops please
upload this so he can see it and give me
permission to put it on the place to her
well I mean we split the revenue
obviously markiplier finally doing his
part
Thank You markiplier very cool this is
what we're doing voice no excuses if
YouTube rewind do send start with huge
clapping year review we all hit this
like button spoilers
it's not gonna happen and in double
spoilers please don't do that
don't hate on the video just because I'm
not in it that's just it's this childish
and stupid there's no reason for it Pete
is joining us and there I am with no
legs tell Petey pie he's not the only
one is it is he playing roblox thinks
that disappear when you need them the
most
keys wallet phone market well not
anymore not anymore these three little
words are a big turn-on subscribe to
booty painful that kind of looks like
jacksepticeye doesn't it I got married
last week we don't like you to series
are you serious
[Music]
[Music]
that's amazing yeah what happened there
I don't know I got a bunch of tweet that
I lost like 20,000 and t-series gained
50 what the Frick second try getting
this into the why I worked pretty hard
on it also they did surgery and grape
all right well now I'm definitely not
showing it okay fine what is it come on
it's amazing absolutely incredible we're
adding this to ass right away there
nine-year-olds we are we actually going
to make a new account for tomorrow 70
pewds I don't know if you can actually
do that I know I mean it's not like I
tried or anything but I think now you
need a cell phone number to create
another account so basically what I'm
telling you it's to steal phones that
was a joke moving on yeah Beauty pie
raising millions of dogs for charity
media I know that's like supposed to be
a mean but literally the same day that
oh yeah Telegraph's same day same day I
said live stream when fans go too far
stay instant and YouTube's next big
problem so ridiculous so they try to
make the whole that hacker thing seem
like a negative art it seems like a
dangerous thing when we're literally out
there you know what this is not even
worth time anyway five mil in YouTube in
six months never done before okay well
this is this meme is just growing more
and more it would be fun if we could hit
5 mil on YouTube in six six what would
it be six weeks we definitely done that
I think okay what we really need is for
Shane Dawson to make an eight-part
documentary on pewdiepie the dark side
okay thank you grinding thank you when
you wake up and see that the difference
of subs went from 10k to 300k seriously
so panic you confirmed PewDiePie is in
for tonight this is his last chance to
be t-series wow that actually looks
pretty cool who did this
Sameer ski thank you Epic Games very
cool buying PewDiePie a $1,000,000
billboard in Times Square a surprise to
be sure but a welcome one doesn't really
cost 1 million though I mean I
appreciate it regardless but I cannot
have a cost 1 million that's brilliant
now damn it I love take talk man that's
why I'm saying it
tick tock is epic rare pic of men
discovering fire are you saying [ __ ]
lasagna is fire because you got damn
riah titties when you spend a million
but only get 100k views poor light is
that true oh this is so sad we're in the
endgame now nope
season 2 just started trust me guys
there's a lot of stuff I've been saving
the best bits
I can't I'm not saying anything more
than that but there's some stuff that
we've only getting started
ok I asked Tommy Wiseau if he supports
PewDiePie in the war against t-series
and he responded
and video about you well back and you
follow them on Twitter okay well what's
your question beautiful background by
the way you haven't give us a really
nice feedback here yeah support him to
the rest of my life Thank You Tommy
Wiseau I support you for the rest of my
life as well god damn what a beautiful
name
why did you create anything people kept
saying it now I see it I'm sorry but
you're come on Ethan is way cuter come
on Peter five verses T series can't
describe be described better pretty much
yes I really appreciate the white font
over the white background really it
really good me like this is all it takes
to get on the white guys this is doing
my part in Israel printed a big magnet
for my car for my work car for Pearce
thank you very much Israel very cool
petition for 257 to host me review that
would be cool honestly maybe I'll try
and track him down that would be awesome
in 60 years
I didn't fought for any World Wars but I
fought in something more important you
know I was a nine-year-old as well once
gonna prank boots when I finally
surpassed him yes it's never happening T
series
get it in your brains that's it for this
week wow I cannot thank you enough
everyone everyone last year
and epic match I'm buying 50
[Music]
[Applause]